the Yonker plan for investment in Europe
Europe needs investment to create more
jobs to help Europe become more
competitive to strengthen our single
market and to support our small
businesses the European Commission and
the European Investment Bank are teaming
up to support strategic investments
worth at least 315 billion euros this is
the European Fund for strategic
investment the EF si9 member states have
already pledged co-financing this money
is targeted to projects that may find it
difficult to secure finance in the
market such as innovative projects that
may need some risk coverage 75% of this
investment capital is designated for
infrastructure and strategic projects
such as transport and telecommunications
energy efficiency initiatives education
infrastructure health care facilities
and so on projects in this category
should require capital in excess of 25
million euros and apply directly to the
EIB but the EF SI is not just about
large projects at least a quarter of
this fund will be available to SMEs and
mid-caps
through financial intermediaries such as
banks or venture capital funds the EF SI
is already working to provide funding to
several projects across Europe like the
construction and operation of a new bio
product mill in arnica Ski Finland with
a capacity to produce 1.3 million tonnes
of renewable fiber or pulp per year or
in Denmark where we are funding energy
related projects with a focus on
offshore wind biomass and transmission
or in 40,000 flats and houses across
France where we are supporting energy
efficiency investments
and in Italy where we are supporting
investment in a mid-sized steel producer
resulting in more competitive and
efficient production these and many
projects like them are creating new jobs
and making European industry more
competitive for more information on the
EFS i you can visit these websites and
follow the links for investment plan
Europe